50 مليونيرا على ارض هذه القريه الريفيه
الصغيره في دوله يعيش نحو ثلثي سكانها تحت
خط الفقر نحن في قريه هيرفري بازار بولايه
مهراشترا الهنديه عام
1972 شهدت نزوحا جماعيا لاهلها بسبب
الجفاف الجديد لكن شابا واحدا تمكن من قلب
الموازين كان طالب الدراسات العليا
الوحيده فيها ويدعى
ويعود له الفضل في عوده السكان الى موطنهم
عام
1989 بعد توليه منصب رئيس القريه
قدم جوجي حمله كبيره بدعم حكومي لجمع مياه
الامطار والحفاظ عليها عبر بناء عشرات
السدود والحصول على قروض بنكيه للمزارعين
وبهذا بدا عصر النهضه في القريه عام 2012
وصل عدد السكان العائدين الى القريه الى
نحو
1150 نسمه موزعين على 235 اسره وارتفع
الدخل الشهري للفرد فيها الى 30 الف روبيه
مقارنه ب 830 روبيه فقط عام 1995
المزارعون في القريه اتبعوا نظاما للري
بالتنقيط للحفاظ على المياه والتربه
وزياده انتاجهم من المحاصيل وتجنبوا زراعه
النباتات التي تتطلب استخداما كبيرا
للمياه
[موسيقى]
في عام
1995 كان عشر اراضي القريه فقط صالحا
للزراعه وكانت 168 اسره من اصل 182 اسره
تقبع تحت خط الفقر لكن بحلول عام 2010 زاد
متوسط دخل القريه 20 ضعفا واصبح 50 قرويا
بها من اصحاب الملايين وثلاثه عائلات فقط
تحت خط الفقر وزاد محصول القريه من 100 طن
في عام 2000 الى 6000 طن في عام 2004
ارتفع انتاج الحليب من 150 لترا يوميا في
منتصف التسعينيات الى 4000 لتر في عام
كل هذه الانجازات اهلت هيفري بازار لتصبح
قريه مثاليه على المستوى الوطني وطلقت
العديد من الجوائز الحكوميه
حتت واحده من اكثر القرط طموحه والملهمه
في الهند
[موسيقى]